i grew up in america i i was actually
born in
the amadia uh or the gaddiani and the
headquarters their old headquarters in
pakistan it was pretty rough you know
and i saw hustlers and pimps and
prostitutes
on the street so i i knew about the
hustle i knew who was hustling who and
why they were hustling and in amadea i
saw it
i didn't see genuine people i saw
you know i saw people who were who were
hiding something i thought
growing up ahmadiyya and islam was close
it was a closer it's you know we were
this is
far away i ended up losing my job
my my brother he ends up spying on my
computer he ends up
he ends up hiring amity's in this
company which is like discriminate
hiring discrimination against the law
and they start spying on my computer and
i'm like the vice president of the
company
and i got these guys spying on my
computer
they go back and tell him hey your
brother's reading and
uh amity awareness websites he's going
and seeing what ahmadiyya is about and
he doesn't go to the mosque he doesn't
give us any money from germany
usa canada and the uk they're bringing
in 100 million a year
and they have about 300 million in
assets
land property buildings where the halifa
lives
in the uk it's a 50 million dollar
facility
where he lives right in pounds i think
it's like 39 million pounds or something
like that
and we caught them storing money
overseas in panama
and their moms are all doing well
so they get the majority of the money
because i found it on the on the balance
sheet
the uh um the amnes
get are living good and they're
uh you can call them the shareholders so
it's the mirza family
and their group of murabis and their
kids are
are super dedicated to the jamaat and
they
they get other people to give money it
started under british colonialism
and uh um in british india and
anywhere the british word um the other
hot spot was egypt and the suez canal
and the british needed that suez canal
so you'll see some of the islamic
scholars saying similar things to what
music law mammoth was saying
like they were all saying that islam is
dead in
egypt a few of them were starting to pop
up so it's a total british
agenda my dad's got the small business
instead of us growing our small business
all the profit my dad's given up
we work seven days a week our house
leaks
um it's terrible since i was seven from
age
seven to eighteen i worked seven days a
week with my dad
never missed the day never got a day off
he never gave me a nickel i said okay
bro i i can't keep quiet
anymore this is out of control on top of
that they're robbing my family
for the mon you know on the financial
aspect
the time and then they got these other
conventions you got to go to
and all the kids are are like cutting
school we're all
we're all hanging out in the parking lot
we don't want to listen to these
speeches you know drop the charade
brother
come to islam it's so much easy
god was speaking through you because
yesterday
man like i was uh making dua
after my prayer and i was just like
allah like just please
give me the ability to just be receptive
and like see what needs to be done next
like give me the the the ability to be
receptive and then
the ability to adapt and just like start
doing these things
you know because it the big changes are
obviously the big changes and
like bro i'm i'm just shocked
that like you were saying everything it
was just like then you just mentioned
the mma thing that
it all was just lining up perfectly bro
like it's like all these gears in my
head were like
just clicking perfectly bro so just a
color
just to color hair bro oh yeah bro i
i appreciate it and here's the thing
quick side note is if you're in a
position to help
anyone don't don't turn it down because
you could be
the answer to that person's prayer
salaam alaikum you are now tuned into
the t3m podcast the realest podcast in
the game
we got the t3m with a very special guest
today
we got brother bashir salaam alaikum
walaikum
brothers how's it going brother
i'm going pretty good um the pandemic's
slowly going away
inshallah uh it seems like it so yeah
um spirits are good right now
alhamdulillah so uh when i was uh just
going about the youtube rabbit hole i
found a video about uh
an ex ahmadi or an ahmadi prof who
kind of exposed ahmadi and believe it or
not ladies and gentlemen that is this
brother right here
so i want you to go a little bit into
you know we're just going to go in
tell us a little bit about your
background you know how old you are
where you live right now
um where you used to grow up everything
your education
just go right in sounds good brother so
yeah uh
i'm i'm in my early 40s um i'm i'm from
uh pakistan from the punjab i'm a
punjabi boy as we all say
you know uh a lot of punjabis out here
you know mostly seek
a lot of sikhs out here but i'm a
punjabi guy
um i grew up in america i was actually
born
in the ahmadiyya uh or the gaddiani and
the headquarters their old headquarters
in
pakistan and i ca my parents brought me
here when i was like six months so i i
don't even remember it like any of that
so
i was six months when i came to america
um got naturalized in like
the early 80s and uh came from a highly
uh um fanatical gaddiani
family now my dad's brothers were not
like that but my dad was like that
um so uh as a part of that
um we would pray every morning uh for
fudger i was the
lesson i wake up to uh to give the is on
i have like a big voice
you know when when it comes to is on you
know i think uh the
we tajweed is important but having a big
voice is also important especially when
there were no like microphones didn't
exist
so um so yeah it came from a fanatical
sacrificial uh gadiani amni family
we had a small business like a tire shop
um use tires
and i worked in that and we'd wake up
every morning
and uh read fajr my dad would teach us
arabic
and we'd read the quran and then we'd go
to work
and the majority of the money that we
would get i'd say almost
all of it we'd give to the amitya
movement
um so uh so
i questioned it when i was 11 and 12
years old my biggest issue with it was
the corruption of the people at that age
you know at that age there was no google
you know google didn't exist in 1990 so
what could you read the only thing that
you could read with was a book if it was
in your house
so um i didn't have access to the
literature of the amadeu movement
and it wasn't even in english there were
maybe a few books in english by
uh mirza glam and so so um
but i gave them the benefit of the doubt
i said okay maybe i'm wrong
maybe you know i grew up in the street
so i grew up in
in the crack 80s if you guys are
familiar with the crack 80s
and how bad it was when there's no
cameras when there's no cameras you can
get beat up and the cops won't know
about it for two hours
you know so uh it was pretty rough you
know and i saw hustlers and pimps and
prostitutes
on the street so i i knew about the
hustle i knew who was hustling who and
why they were hustling and in amadea i
saw it
i didn't see genuine people i saw
you know i saw people who were who were
hiding something and
my dad would do a dawah at our tire shop
you know and he would love to tell
christians that jesus is dead
and he had me memorize all the arguments
and um
et cetera et cetera so uh but i had a
problem
um uh doing the dawah because
he he wouldn't say that um amnes
believed that jesus died in india
right and i i could not understand why
would he start a conversation with a
christian
saying jesus is dead but then not say
that we believe that he died in india at
age 125
which is the most ridiculous thing the
most ludicrous thing
anyone has ever heard you know uh forget
about jesus
being dead being ridiculous and
ludicrous this is even more
ludicrous than that so i didn't share
the same conviction
of dawa i just couldn't do it right so
so um but i gave him the benefit of the
doubt i said maybe i'm just a kid maybe
i'm wrong
whatever so i continue to believe in it
um
when i was 19 i joined the us air force
and uh uh i worked on i worked on like
boeing aircraft
and and was going to college for
aeronautical and engineering
and fixed a lot of aircraft in
california i'm a california kid
you know uh uh and grew up in cali
and um grew up in the diversity
and um uh joined the air force uh
traveled around the world i i was in
when 9 11
happened so that was rough um my brother
and dad told me never pray with muslims
gaddiani enemies will not pray with
muslims
so i i i was in texas and i wrote home
in boot camp saying hey
i'm gonna go to this mosque there's a
mosque on bait on base they have a space
for muslims
to go and pray all of a sudden like two
days later or like a week later i get a
letter from my brother
saying don't go you are not allowed to
do that it's not
cool uh you know and i said okay i won't
go so i
they they deterred me from learning
about islam for me even being around
muslims uh kadhiani and these
you know in the west don't even have
muslim friends normally so
so um as i was about to get out so i was
there for 9 11
and i actually fixed some of the
aircraft that bombed afghanistan
um i mostly fixed uh refuelers but i
also had hands on
the b1s and the b52s so um and i grew up
a mechanic so i was real fast with it um
uh with the wrenches and the crowbars
and the screwdrivers and i didn't care
if i got dirty so
so that's a little bit of the background
and then i my parents wanted me to get
married i was like 24 25 so they so i
agreed to it
uh i went to rubla again where i was
born and it which is like their
unofficial headquarters and i married an
amity girl from rugba
and in rubble i was confused because the
mosques were empty
and and i was hanging out with my cousin
and this guy is smoking hash all day
right and i'm like and i'm just shocked
about this whole thing
right and then uh so i'm like i gotta
check my email
so i go to the internet cafe and these
guys are watching porn in the internet
cafe
in the most holiest city the second most
holiest city
of amazia so i immediately get up and
leave
um go back and tell my cousin hey what's
going on he goes oh that's very normal
that's very normal around here so i'm
just confused and
um books were in urdu by 2004 like two
were in english
or three were in english now it's like
40 of them in english like half of them
so i could read urdu but very slow you
know it's something i don't
want to do you know what i mean because
i got to sit down
and with my alphabet just to be sure so
so i started reading
and i was in college i graduated college
and i
i figured out this prophethood thing and
i said what
i said hold on in islam chapter 33 verse
40
muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
didn't have he's not the father of any
man
and and he's the la he's the hatman navy
he's the final prophet and the best
prophet
um no new prophet can be born
um and i figured out the islamic theory
the islamic theory islam is going to
return
but he was born before so that doesn't
affect
things it's like um you know uh
there's exceptions to many rules in fact
uh uh isa al-islam's life is a sign
it's it's an exception the way he was
born and he
you know with the help of allah he
brought a bird back to life and a human
back to life
uh etcetera right so i i i was perplexed
um then i found out there were
lahorianis and i i had heard about them
i was like who are these little horrians
well
um the most famous lahorean was a guy
named uh
um muhammad ali not the boxer uh i think
the boxer took
his name so um um the lahorian these
denied the prophethood
of mirza glamour and i was like i was
like
okay with the shia and sunni issue
the shia aren't denying the prophethood
of messenger
you know like this is a big issue this
isn't like a
small issue so so i go to my local
mosque and i ask the imam
what's did did mr mahmoud say he wasn't
a prophet
initially and then towards the end of
his life he said he made a mistake
and he discovered a new type of
prophethood that he never knew
existed and so i asked this to the
the md imam and they don't call
themselves moms they call themselves
rugby like uh like rabbi
and he's dumps he doesn't know he
doesn't answer the question
so he he he he immediately calls me an
honorably in front of like 20 people
and i'm just like what what how am i not
an enemy anymore
because i asked a question about
prophethood right
so he closed the session and then
afterwards he made me clean he made me
vacuum the
mosque and i couldn't you know i was
like maybe this is some third world
primitive way that they teach kids
i don't know but i'm asking like i'm a
college graduate at this point
i've read these boring boeing technical
manuals on aircraft maintenance that
make no sense you got to read them like
50 times
and then go actually go and do the job
for it to kick in
so i'm like i can rewrite pretty good i
i've read islam
from just the um uh i think uh tips here
even cathedral had come online in oh six
or
or oh seven and i was reading it and i'm
like okay uh
this is not right it's not i thought
growing up
ahmadiyya and islam was close it was a
closer
it's you know we were this is far away
it's not as close as they they uh made
it sound so
um uh um so
so so he still didn't have an answer he
still didn't have an answer
that that's how how they got rid of me
and at the time i was working in my in
my brother's company that was a small
business
uh it's a long story you know how he
came into control of it
so i started asking him hey bro you know
like
like a bro would ask his older brother
bro do do you know what this is
do you know that islam is different and
this is
he immediately turned pale immediately
right and now the business is doing good
he won't give me a raise
um he won't make me a business partner
and we grew up in this thing right
he just won't give me any time off i
literally didn't take a vacation i
i think i worked for eight years didn't
take a vacation
i took one sick day right so
so um so so all that's going on
and i'm like okay i'm in trouble i'm
married to one
how am i gonna get out of this you know
i so i just said okay i just won't say
anything
i'll just back off the religion all
together so i stopped going to their
mosque
i stopped praying i stopped doing um
ramadan
i stopped doing all of that and i said
okay i need to figure out
what this is i gotta back off
go back to zero and figure out what's
going on here
and alhamdulillah that was what
what caused me to go back to the quran
go back to the hadith
and uh and that's a long and short i i
don't want to take too much time to give
you a longer version but
uh but i ended up losing my job my my
brother he ends up spying on my computer
he ends up he ends up hiring amethyst in
this
company which is like discriminate
hiring discrimination against the law
and they start spying on my computer and
i'm like the vice president of the
company
and i got these guys spying on my
computer
they go back and tell him hey your
brother's reading and
uh amity awareness websites he's going
and seeing what ahmadiyya is about and
he doesn't go to the mosque he doesn't
give us any money he doesn't go
into for for ramadan for dharavi nothing
they're like
he's he's uh he's he's a fake he's a
fake so
uh i end up they they they end up ended
up
um poisoning my wife against me it was
terrible i
ended up having to divorce her um
crazy crazy story but they planned allah
had a better plan
while all this was happening i ended up
getting two master's degrees
i uh i got a doctorate um in in
education
uh three or four years ago and and my
graduates i had like an mba and a
master's in
management my undergraduate aeronautical
engineering which i
totally left but um yeah that's the long
and short of it and then
as i quit ahmadiyya in 2015 i i sat down
with the quran again i saw so i
officially quit in 2015.
um i sent an email to my dad and my
brother
i i went and spoke to my dad i told my
dad i told my dad the reason i put out
this mr blah blah was on opium his whole
life just look at his eyes
you know and where i'm from in the hood
they see that as a customer a potential
customer
when your eyes look like that right so
so um that's what's on my dad and uh
and that was how i quit so then it took
me six months to a year
in 2016. i read the quran and pondered
on it
and then i said the shahadah with a
locally mom
i love the guy he's a younger mom too uh
um so uh i said the shahadah came back
to salah
came back to uh well i don't think i was
ever on salah because when you're at
kaliyani and
it doesn't even count so i mean i don't
know
what that's even about but uh now i find
comfort in
um islam you know um
i find comfort in in salat in ramadan
in knowing that when i die i'm gonna
return to allah
um and as i read more and more and more
uh i i read the truth about isa al-islam
the details
and yeah that's the long and short of it
brother i hope i hope i didn't go too
long
you're responding perfect one last thing
what are you currently doing now how was
life going
oh so so so right now uh i'm like a
tenured accounting professor
um um and so that's what i'm doing i
teach mostly online i've i've like
pioneered
the curriculum for free textbooks and
uh yeah i mostly do that and i was going
to the gym
but with the pandemic uh no more
basketball
no more pickups so uh in the last year
alhamdulillah
i started a blog a youtube channel and
i've been working on that
um working with other uh xmd's um
inviting them to islam as best as i can
that was a little hard especially when
people are uh
are cussing at you on instagram i've got
empties on me
on me all the time talking about my kids
talking about
uh spreading false rumors about me so
just trying my best to tell people how i
came to islam and
hopefully allah will guide them
i mean you got hella enemies man that's
a sign that you're speaking the truth
because all of the prophets um you know
they all had they all had a lot of
opposition you know if you're speaking
what's going with the status quo if
you're aligning with ahmadi values
they're not going to speak against you
right but anytime you want to say
something against it it's going to be
it's going to raise some eyes
right for sure man for sure yeah
so uh romney you got any questions
lot so what would you say was the first
um
argument that you heard from the ahmadis
that you're just like no that doesn't
make sense
what was like the the beginning of the
end for ahmadiyya
yeah yeah so um when when i was a kid
andy's believed that if you eat pork
it'll make you gay
and i was like but i know amd's who are
gay
you know i was like hold on you know
well
that makes no sense what so so that was
when i was a teenager like that
and then the jesus in india jesus um
traveled to india and died in india in
kashmir
that's far-fetched that's just
if you guys have a quran handy they um
reference chapter 23 verse 50
which talks about the birth of isa
al-islam not in his death
and they flipped it and said no it's
about his death right
so then they also say not just issa at
last long when went to india
mariam also went to india and it was
like
why did she run why did she run away
they didn't have any beef with her
you know they weren't after her she was
like an older woman at this point she
was like
if if isa last long was 33 she was like
45
or something so didn't make any sense
though
those two things and i didn't even know
about the other stuff
until late
that's crazy dude yeah that's crazy
craziness absolute craziness and then
when i grew up and went to college and
did the research
i found how they came to this and i was
like
no that's academic dishonesty total
dishonesty
why you know okay i understand if a
muslim says
oh i want to believe that isa islam is
dead
okay bro you can believe whatever you
want is sitting in your house and you do
you want to believe something
that makes no sense okay but these guys
have a motive
and the reason they're saying it is
because they want to prove
is a prophet and the messiah and the
magni and he also claimed to be krishna
you know that was his marketing strategy
it's something for every
for everyone i don't know why he didn't
claim to be buddha so he can go after
the buddhist
but he he claimed to be the second
coming of krishna but that's nowhere in
the
hindu literature anywhere that krishna
is going to come again so
um subhanallah so yeah i know you
told us you did aeronautical engineering
so right now we're going to do some
reverse engineering
let's go right back alright we talked
about the background let's talk about
what is it about for a lot of people
following so far it sounds like a cult
it sounds like this trap but i want you
to talk about it how did it start where
did it originate from
what separates it from real islam
right right right so it started under
british colonialism
and uh um in british india and
anywhere the british word um the other
hot spot was
egypt and the suez canal and the british
needed that suez canal
so you'll see some of the islamic
scholars saying similar things to what
musical arm mammoth was saying
like they were all saying that islam is
dead in
egypt a few of them were started to pop
up so it's a total british
agenda and here's here's how it happened
in 1857 there was a huge mutiny amongst
the british army of indian soldiers
it had to do with the enfield rifle the
enfield rifle
needed to be greased with a beef and and
pork
packet of fat if you shoot it a few
times you gotta lose lose your gun
so the muslim and the hindu soldiers
were like we're not gonna bite into this
and pour it into our gun it's it's
against our religion
so they rebelled against the british and
almost one uh mirza glamon's family
his dad and his uncles and his brothers
went and helped the british
they didn't help the muslims who or even
the hindus um
and remember there weren't that many
guns in british india
right right so whoever has the guns is
going to win the war it's really that
simple
right if you got rocks or whatever
you're not going to win bro
so um the mirza family did that for the
british
the british gave mirza glam and his dad
an entire village
six other villages a pension so uh
so mercenaries is now living in the lack
of luxury he didn't go he was like 20
years old or something like that
or like 17 but he broke his right arm
when he was a kid so he can't lift
a cup of tea uh forget a a rifle or a
sword
right so so uh then he goes and works
for the british government he worked as
a clerk
in their court so what profit do you
know that worked the job
in the court of the job or the court of
the enemy
you know what i mean so he goes and does
that for four years he learns their law
system
he learns you know what we i mean can
you imagine
uh working in a courthouse for four
years and hearing arguments every day
and learning all the loopholes and
learning if you go to court i'm going to
court because i'm divorced right
all you got to do is go there and have a
story because that's it it doesn't
matter if it's true or not
right they'll hear you out so he knew
all this
another phenomenon was going on i'm not
sure if your brother's a pakistani or
indian
but uh the oligarch college in india um
um uh have you guys heard of that
sounds familiar yeah um cersei and
amitan
no yeah so he comes out
with the aligarh college and this new
idea he talks about
muslims should obey the british et
cetera et cetera he says he's the first
muslim ever in the history of the world
in in the 1870s to say uh isa al islam
is dead and never coming back
he doesn't just say that he says that
that isa
was actually on the cross he was hung
on the cross whereas muslims never
believed this muslim
chapter 4 verse 157 um
he was not tongue you know salibu um
so so andy's flipping and saying no he
was not killed by crucifixion
but the sentence before that is he was
not killed
right he was not killed nor was he hung
so
no he was hung but he came down he was
alive
and uh and he died at that point right
so
that that's the second okay he also ser
saying
was the first muslim ever in the history
of the world to deny the miracles of isa
al islam
he said he said never never brought the
dead to life he said
he also said uh muhammad sallallahu
alaihi didn't go on the mirage
physically
it was a dream he said uh adam alaslan
was not the first man
he said uh um uh uh isa al-islam wasn't
born miraculously
um so almost everything he said mr
glaman was
[Music]
like 60 miles away from aligarh they
even invited him to come give a lecture
he shows up and then he flakes because
he never gave a public lecture
he never led a hook but he never led
prayers
uh um right so
so this is the background of what mirza
glamout is growing up
into someone else's laid the groundwork
right so
so mr iguana says all just claim to be a
prophet
and muslims are listening to me because
muslims aren't listening to sir saying
that
they're like who the hell is he right
we're not going to listen to this guy
so so mr man writes his uh brahimi
ahmadiyya he says
hey muslims of india i'm going to do you
guys a favor
i'm going to write 300 arguments in
support of islam give me your money
so muslims give them money and say hey
you know mirza blah blah
um have you guys heard of the ali hadith
yeah so it's sort of like the wahhabis
of india not exactly like
it's similar right and in india
the um the mughal empire it was hanafi
faith the ottomans were also kind of
fake in west africa it's maliki fake in
east africa africa is shafi
so muslims don't have sex like this
muslim in islamic empires
you could be a sufi you know and shias
were tolerated
but you you can't really break into
different sects
and et cetera so um um mr blah blah blah
affiliated with the ali hadees
uh and and they gave him a lot of money
he he writes this book
and it's incomplete he writes uh
four volumes and in the 300 arguments he
only gives one and his one argument
he says allah speaks to him so it's like
and he he in that book he um denies
that um isa did any miracles
um right so he's leading on
he's just leaning on uh so that's the
backdrop
the um some of the ulama already did uh
since he denies the miracles of isa or
islam you're denying the quran if you
deny a verse of the quran
you like you're like not a muslim right
so he was immediately called a kafir
right so a lot of people said no
let's give him the benefit of the doubt
maybe we're wrong a few years later he
claims to be the messiah he says
he's 50 years old he says i
i had a dream uh and uh
uh i was told that esau islam is dead
and it's like dude but sir saiyans
and like these the guys in college have
been saying it for 15 years
no one told them i mean they didn't hear
a whisper
you know where did you get this whisper
from all right so
so that's the backdrop he claims to be
the messiah this is 1891
and then he says all the hadiths on the
madly are wrong
and he says dude there's only one hadith
on the mandy that's accurate
and it's from i think it's
a famous one um um
no uh or um la matifisa
it basically says there's no media
except isa well well this is
a a different ease this is a weak this
is weak
bro stop taking the weak hadith and the
weak stuff
and and put murakida on it that's
incorrect you go to the clear things
and and um develop so
he claims to be the maddie a few years
later uh in a slick way
he just wrote it on the beginning on the
top of his book the uh
maddy of the era or something like that
but he denies prophethood
he says no i'm not a prophet he says
when when when isa is gonna return
he wouldn't be a prophet so i'm not a
prophet and just i'm ahead of this
right so for ten years he says anyone
who claims to be prophet is watchable
he said it he says he's a kafir you
can't claim to be a prophet
in 1901 he writes a book um correction
of
error and he says i made a mistake
i was a prophet this whole time it's
been 20 years
i was a prophet i didn't know it anyone
can be a prophet
he says when when you recite the surah
fatiha
you're saying uh i think the last
sentence or the second to last sentence
is
guide us on the right path uh he says
everyone's praying to become a prophet
i'm the only one the first one to
achieve it
he's saying confidence achievable which
is
not true right i mean if it was
achievable abu bakr
i mean homer usman ali
if it was achievable it's not achievable
uh
um even the prophet had his son ibrahim
that died
you know and if he would have lived he
would have been a prophet so
so that's what rattled me about mr obama
about him he lied about his prophethood
for 20 years
finally claims it uh the lahorean they
say no
he didn't claim it finally uh then him
is starts to to claim to be the second
coming of muhammad sallam
for allah he says because the mandy
that is supposed to be just like
muhammad sallallahu
right in a lot of ways i think he would
have the same name
so he's trying to spin this issue right
but the magni is separate
from the from the messiah right the
messiah is the prophet the matthew is
not a prophet so
a lot of twists and turns brother like
you can't learn this stuff in a year
i'm about 16 years deep you know and i
really started figuring it out
maybe just five years ago so those are
the claims of this guy okay and then he
says
oh yeah so initially he said in 1891 he
says no uh
issa is dead never coming back hi misa
there
and he says oh he was buried in israel
he was buried at
age 33 maybe in galilee uh maybe
somewhere out there
then he says no he lived 90 years longer
and died in india and we found the grave
he doubles down and he finds a grave by
some guy named
asa in kashmir and he says that's the
guy's great
well the people that own the grave say
it's not
right so it's just ridiculous and and
then we recently checked his source
he quoted the history of kashmir which
was written like like um
three or four hundred years ago they say
this use awesome character
was the son of a local prince and he
existed before islam got here
he's and he had a mother in all of that
so how could he be issa alas
so so that's the long and short of it
brother
[Music]
so this this really seems to me like
what's called a sharpshooter fallacy
like
imagine you're looking at a blank wall
right just a white wall
and you take a gun and you shoot a hole
in the wall then
you're like okay that's a nice shot you
walk up to it and you start drawing the
bullseye
around the hole you shot and you you say
look everyone i got a bullseye
right right that's essentially they're
doing they have the hole in the wall
that
this guy is a prophetic person right
and then they start taking what they can
and drawing the circles around saying
see
we have all these evidences for it most
of which
um are either twisting the words making
things up completely
um i guess the whatever it is it falls
into
one of those two categories and it's
it's really sad subhanallah
because like how do you get past the
verse in the quran
the prophets and seal implies the last
of them right it implies that
and another recitation literally the
last of them you can't get around that
but still they try and find a way um
let's put a lot
it's it's crazy and uh um they actually
made that very argument and they said
they messed up so um and the arguments
contradict each other
in in the 1920s um they said if it had
been hot them
then we wouldn't believe he's the last
prophet but it didn't it said
so when everyone looked it up they said
oh you're wrong because the garage both
of them are accepted
that's equally good enough so then they
said okay
we believe he is the last prophet but in
terms of
law bearing so it's like in terms
there's no such thing
as love in the quran
the quran talks about nabi and navies
who are sent to a hostile nation are
rasool
that's it they all follow allah whatever
allah tells them so
yeah it's all madness it's all madness i
just smiled through it i tried to
found a lot so this was a movement
started
basically because of british colonialism
subhanallah absolutely bro
um the british so remember in europe
they can't grow sugar
it's too cold right so they had to
import sugar
and in pakistan there's a perfect
weather for sugar cane
so uh uh and diamonds and we
and you name it so uh india was the the
crown jewel of the british empire
well they wanted muslims to chill out
and no jihad okay i forgot to mention
the
then muslims could just basically die
out because if we're attacked we can't
defend ourselves
that's a part of jihad um also waking up
for fajr
is also seen as jihad because like it's
struggling for the for the sake of allah
so wow
that's crazy um what what do you think
gets people hooked on this because do
you think it's it's lies
distortion um omitting certain things
like if someone
were to try and convert somebody else to
to ahmadiyya
they obviously wouldn't give them this
full picture we're giving them so what
do they tell them
yeah so in africa uh um ahmadiyya has
uh they spread into the british colonies
of africa
but before world war ii not the french
colonies not the german colonies not the
portuguese colonies
because they didn't like them but the
british were like
we're we're going to import amethya to
west africa
right so in west africa and east africa
they didn't tell them we was going to
claim to be a prophet
that they just said he was the magnet
here to save you from the british
so that's what it is it depends on the
audience
uh if you're a hindu they'll say oh he's
krishna
you see what i'm saying if you're if
you're a shia they'll start with the
madney
um if you're a muslim they don't want to
talk about the prophecy
they're like let's not even go there
because they know they're cooked
so they'll say let's argue about isa
lasslam being dead or not
and they'll say dude look uh ibn abbas
in
in bukhari it's written in in bukhari
that ibn abbas said
um means
right so we looked it all up oh it's not
in bukhari it's a chapter heading
in bukhari it's not part of the
authentic bukhari
right and what did even a boss believe
uh um even the boss and some muslims
did say that mutufika can mean death
and the way it could fit is when isa
alaslan physically returns he's going to
die
you know and they said chapter 3 verse
55 is out of sequence
um the phrase
i think right so they said okay maybe
raphael got comes first
inimoto afiqa comes second right so
that's what even the boss is talking
about but they're like nope
he said you said well i didn't mean
death he says it does
and it's like dude but we've given you
the context now
stop making this argument to people who
don't know but they keep making it they
won't stop
yeah yeah i find that um in fact oh
sorry to cut you off
in fact they're not growing at all i uh
um per my estimation there's 150 000 of
them in the whole world
wow 150 000 but when you google the
stats brother you get 100 million plus
yeah so what they did was uh um they
claimed to have 200 million in 2002.
i thought it was true i mean in 2002
could you figure it out you could lie
they were claiming
40 million converts in india alone in
2001.
40 million congress brother in india
they got barely 10 000
and this is a country of 1.5 billion
and this is where subhanallah uh um
allah has cursed their tongues
you know uh uh um some um and these
tried to criticize
my arabic i'm like dude okay i'm not an
olive i can read my dad taught me how
um how to read i'm not gonna leave the
salat at a mosque
but like in my house with my kids
probably you know
so so uh they went through the arabic of
the halifax he makes 27 with 20 plus
mistakes in fact there
and i'm talking basic mistakes the iem
bro you're halifa can't say the ie like
what are you talking about bro
that means he didn't learn it as a kid
so subhanallah um but so
in africa they get government funding to
start schools
and they've been pretending to the world
that they
like for example in in tanzania that
they pretend to have 2.5 million
avenues in tanzania i looked it all up
it's like 5 000
right and it's real easy to figure out
uh because they
um they'll tell you how many mosques
they have well
if you only have 10 mods in the whole
country
how can you have 2.5 million adherents
it's just not possible so
yeah and so i could reverse uh engineer
and
and go on all their twitter accounts all
their facebook accounts all their
research
you know um and i'll spend like a day i
spend like a day on
on tanzania i was like two okay so
here's what they did
um there was a pew research study and i
don't believe any of those by the way
and i'm i'm like a doctoral dude this is
what i do
so i'm gonna tell you they're all fake
so pew does a research study they asked
a hundred muslims in tanzania
what religion they were 15 of them
said they were amazing well they hyper
imposed that
onto the whole country and they say 15
percent of all muslims in tanzania are
going and it's like dude you can't do
that
that's just not right and we who who are
the hundred that they that that they
surveyed what's you were they what men
was it men or women was it in the big
city
was it in a village you know if it was
in the big city and it's
you know if there's you know in fremont
california there's hella afghans right
right right if you say 20 of fremonts
afghani you can't say 20
of america's afghani
so it's total academic dishonesty no
one's joining
they recently said only 100 people
joined in america
in 2020 and they spent like five million
on on uh dallas or something like that
same thing in canada dude you got 100
people and out of those hundred people
about 80 of them joined because they
fell in love with a girl
or a guy and so so
you so when andy can't marry outside of
media
for them to marry someone legally and
kosher whatever you want to call it
that person's got to convert to amendia
and wait
a year and pay money for a year then
they'll let you marry him
what yeah the mormon church
it is so so this is the jehovah's
witnesses the mormons of islam
uh even worse than that even worse next
at least the mormons don't lie about
their membership
you know i think there's like a website
with a ticker for them and it's like 10
million i think
which is possible because they have a
state so
so yeah yeah um i want to go back to um
the talk about jesus
and and and all this because i find that
a lot of the time
uh like even with my experience talking
to ahmadis
it always goes to isa alaihissalam and i
feel like the reason for that is because
they feel like they have much more
substance
because they talk about the idea of
prophethood where they're going to go if
they talk about the idea of of
ghatam and the being khatim and nabi and
where are they going to go right if they
talk about the hadith as a whole even
where where are they going to go because
prophet saw himself in the hadith he
said that there will be no prophet after
me
so like even with that where are they
going to go so i find a lot of the time
they try and uh just talk about isa
alaysalam
and it's because this word tawafa in the
quran and to refer to
uh what he's saying allah says in quran
about islam about jesus that
he will basically tawaffa which means uh
according to
bukhari whatever one understanding of
tuafa is is to take the soul away which
means death
so when when the brother said moat death
that's what it means
so they latch on to that and they say
look allah says he's going to take the
soul of jesus and that means death he's
going to kill jesus
but in the quran the the way sunnis
interpret it and translate it is
uh i will raise you to myself right no
i i will capture you raising is a refund
really yeah yeah so so wafa
can mean death it can also mean sleep
you see what i mean but in the context
of isa last long
well far means i took you i captured you
okay in chapter 3 5 and
chapter 5 verse verse 117 okay
if someone can take a filler pull that
out look it up
yeah yeah pull it up so so in
it's uh chapter 3 verse 55 um
i will i will capture you and lift you
towards me
and uh uh interestingly mirza glam
before he made his claims he uh
translated what to afika as the same
thing i will take you
and then later he says oh i was wrong
um so i usually use the um
translation by um dr mustafa
yep that that's the one on quran.com i
mean yeah
yeah i mean they have multiple they have
multiple buttons yeah
i think the first one that pulls up like
on default yeah i think so because it's
amazing masha'allah if anyone wants to
copy the quran i suggest this one
but um so yeah uh remember
when allah said oh jesus i will take you
and raise you up to myself i will
deliver you from those who disbelieve
and elevate your followers above
disbelievers on the day of judgement
then to me you will all return and i
will settle all your disputes
so um
read that arabic you'll
so some of the muslim scholars said okay
maybe this verse is not a
sequence and maybe uh raphael god comes
first
then he'll cause isa to die it's like an
alternate
but we don't need that you know because
uh chapter 4 verse 159
clearly says before isa's death which
what that means he hasn't died yet right
and then there's another verse
uh chapter 43 verse 61 um isa al-islam
is the a sign of the final hour
and then there's multiple um hadith the
hadith from sahih buhari so
uh and these will go into the the
inauthentic hadith
in sahih bukhari abu herrera says
chapter 4 verse 159
and he connects it with 4361 and he says
isa hasn't died yet
it's sahih mirza blah blah blah you need
um you know how he got out of this
oh he he called herrera a guppy
which is so dishonest guppy is
everywhere that means like stupid
or like lacking knowledge abu herrera
bro
what are you talking about like he
related like 20 of the hadees
you can't say he lacked understanding
bro
that's i mean i can't even say i'm
surprised to be honest after
uh some of the other things i heard um
but yeah
so to uh you're right about the uh the
word my bad
uh with tawaffa it uh means take you
right i will take you or capture as you
said
and in in a lot of cases it can mean
death
it can't be like it's a word like uh um
hatman navin
can also mean best but he doesn't take
away from the lack
the last is always there but we can be
adventurous
and you know say he's also the best
yeah yeah so um
it does it can mean uh to cause death
oh my god bismillah pardon me it's a
hard one well no
uh the root is wafa so so the
phraseology muthuafika only appears once
in the quran
yeah and that's for the last long right
but the rule
is is is wafa yeah
yeah and what does that mean originally
what does root word the root word mean
uh it ca it can have multiple meanings
based on context
uh welfare can mean death or it can mean
a taking in fact
on my blog i found all instances of the
wafa in the quran and about half of the
time
it means taking giving a full reward
uh you know um and the other half is
talking about people dying so yeah
yeah in fact i believe it's chapter 30
39 43 if you can pull that up um
allah says we have uh waffle
every night and um lot uh captures our
soul
every night you know but we're not dead
you see what i mean so we'll fall can ha
it happens to us every day
yeah yeah every time we go to sleep if
you take a nap
um that like really opened me up i i
said okay every night our soul's being
captured by allah that's probably why we
dream
right and i was like okay that's an
entirely different uh i'm trying to
thought
yeah yeah speaking of dreams speaking of
dreams i want to get to that in a minute
but um i heard since we're on this topic
i heard that um
the word when they used it originally it
meant to take something and eventually
it became
uh the taking of the soul and that's
when it began to mean death and
when it comes to sleep um sleep is like
a state of death except we're not
actually dead
uh because our our souls essentially
allah takes our souls for that period of
time before we return
uh so just to clear up the confusion
because a lot of the time i want people
to be prepared
a lot of the time people will pull up
this verse and i had one sister
uh message me about this and she was
confused because every time twafa comes
up it means death and so on and so forth
and uh it caused her some trouble and
then it caused me some trouble as well
so i wanted to get that out of the way i
feel like that's
the argument they really run to in in my
experience but speaking of
speaking of dreams i heard he said a lot
of weird things like he saw in a dream
that he was god
uh and all these other things so
can you get more into that please yeah
yeah so
so he claims to be a prophet but he
doesn't see
a gibrael what what prophet in history
didn't see jibrael
so it's like what is this guy even
talking about right so he says no
uh i'm getting these dreams and i can
predict future events
so so one of the first things he says is
uh
uh he wants to marry his niece he's got
like a triple niece
if you live in the village you know what
a triple niece is that means you're
related to her in like three different
ways or something like that
so he wants to marry this like 13 year
old girl he's like 50
they tell him no you're not going to
marry her we're not going to give you
our daughter he said he says okay if you
don't marry her to me i just had a dream
that her dad's going to die in three
years her new husband's going to die
and she will eventually come to me right
so then he has another dream where he
sees her naked
it's like bro you're talking you're
publicly talking about your niece bro
and you're saying you saw her naked in a
dream and she was shaved and
what is this what is this stuff man you
know so
so my conclusion on all that was uh
if you take opium now i'm not sure where
you guys are from india is a lot of
opium
if you take opium you will have these
crazy dreams and there's scientific
like research on this um
so he would just publish his dreams some
of them make no sense
like his name mirza glam and kadiani he
says that equals 13 years in like some
sort of numerology
or something like that or at 1400 years
so he says
that means i was supposed to come 1400
years after muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
right so he's he's he's publishing this
stuff
and none of them make any sense man i i
gave a few examples
for allah what is wrong with this guy
man you know and then he says
he was pregnant he says he was pregnant
himself
and then he gave birth to isa and that's
how he became
isa what is this guy
on bro the only solution is he's on that
opium that codeine you know
what the rappers are talking about these
days that lean
underneath whatever you want to call it
he's all that good stuff
and he doesn't have to smoke it um they
just sprinkle it into their chai
in the village back then so and tell us
tell us a little bit about that opium
you know i i went into your twitter and
i saw a lot of
different you know pictures and proofs
that you had you know i saw opium i saw
wine
you know i saw a lot of stuff that i
didn't think i would see without his
yeah he's getting wrecked right every
day i mean
because so remember in the village time
stands still they didn't even have
clocks really to where they're like
you you got to be 8 a.m you got to be
worried no no no no
so so he's got the opium uh so he never
admitted to it in his lifetime
remember that remember that he's he had
this uh
a diabetic problem where he says he's
gotta urinate a hundred times a day
he says he's got chronic diarrhea and he
says i still won't take
obligation even though people of doctors
have prescribed it
for my bad diabetes i got i'm a bad
diabetic
i won't take it he refused to take it so
after he
dies his son say yeah he was taking off
right and maybe that's why he never led
the prayer
because he's so high on this opium he
can't
you know and um so he would stand on the
right side of the imam
and i'll tell you a crazy story he had a
follower who used to jump rose
during salah and fondle his body
during salah and this was like a normal
thing
in ghadian it's like the weirdest story
so this same follower
um after mr mehmed died it came out he
was the guy who go and get the tonic
wine for him too
right so he's got the tonic wine pork
line
a cocoa wine he also got a pharmacy
right most
most most rappers will tell you i'm
giving drugs out like i don't run i'm a
doctor or something like that
so he's giving it out right he's got
access to it
just look at his eyes you know there's a
famous story he couldn't open his eyes
right like how high can you be if you
you really can't open your eyes so
that was a deal breaker for me and that
was before i knew all this other stuff
i said he's on it bro and one of my
cousins on one of my nephews
used to always say he's like dude i just
look at his eyes i'm like what is the oh
i can't because they have this picture
in there in every amd's house
it's on the wall so you could be praying
and you look to your right it is mirza
as heck and he's looking at it
so so the opium thing and and i've
debated amnes on it
um they they won't admit to anything
dude forget
it they're not they're taught to never
confess look
um even my brothers so i play a lot of
basketball bro and
when when there's no refs i believe in
the honor system
if there's a ref bro okay let the ref
call it you know what i mean i'm not i'm
not here to call
stuff on myself so so i play sports with
um
um amnes and they would cheat like they
could be looking the opposite way they
called
a guy out of bounds and i'd be like what
well you didn't even see this thing man
you're calling somebody out of bounds
and you didn't see it like
what you should say you didn't see it so
they would just uh puppet these
arguments
um they just believe in it they have
faith they've had some experience
and that's the story and i'm like
brother that's okay whatever
but in in islam the first thing muhammad
was told to do was recite
you know i mean we're supposed to learn
the quran we're supposed to read and
educate ourselves
and read the hadith you know i never
read sahih bukhari when i was a kabhiani
yemi
or when i was growing up you know
in like the last few years i was reading
it you know but i never read it so
as a muslim so subhanallah um uh
you know when when you read all these
things um even alcohol in islam
it wasn't forbidden to the last six
months of the life of muhammad so it was
forbidden at the end
you know but you can't go back to it i
mean it's over
it it's over so yeah that's the opium
thing that's how he did it
he lived with some doctors he lived with
his team of ghost riders
they gave bajuma for him they gave
speeches for him
and that's who this guy was
the amount of money that i'm thinking is
processing from
the the genesis of uh
oh i just did all the research so in the
uk and canada
they are forced to publish their balance
sheet in america they don't have to
publish it in germany and i publish it
from what i've gathered from germany usa
canada and the uk they're bringing in
100 million a year
and they have about 300 million in
assets
land property buildings where the halifa
lives
in the uk it's a 50 million dollar
facility
where he lives right in pounds i think
it's like 39 million pounds or something
like that
so they are killing it right now
right uh and and we caught them storing
money overseas in panama
in like an overseas um tax-free haven
right it was a big big story
uh that's how you wash money you know
donald trump had non-profits
he still does so so what you do is you
take your money from your for-profit
give it as a donation to your non-profit
if the money goes out of the country the
accounting standards are not the same
and you're in you're an accounting
professor right so everything you say
about what i teach i'm like this is how
you hide your money
this is how you launder money you know i
hope people don't do it
but i can tell them how there's a quick
disclaimer nobody laundered money it's
uh
legal felony and you will um yeah we
arrested and tried for that
we're not correct exactly
so it's like it's for every reason in
the book other than for allah right
that that they they start and they
continue
i remember hearing that um soon after
the apostle i said
you had imams come up that would give a
khuttaba and at the end of the
they would make up some hadith where the
prophet saw allah said
uh after the after the give donations to
the khatib
and and all this stuff give give
donations to the man that gave the
lecture
after the lecture is done um after they
finish giving a lecture
so pathetic how people you know they
sell the afterlife
for whatever little game they make in
this life it's crazy and
so on top of that the british government
so it was beneficial to
to join if you became a goddamni
in british india that was a fast track
of getting a government job
because the british government can trust
you now right you agree with him do they
trust you of course
if you're a muslim they're like oh we
don't you got to prove it
but if you're you're an alien you're
going to get a good job
so that was the incentive um
in mirza mirza glamour claimed half a
million uh amnes before he died that's a
lie there was like
15 000 barely 15 000.
um um even my dad my dad converted to
amelia
he he went to go live with his uncle and
uh i think his mom but his mom
you know my grandparents were illiterate
they didn't know what it was
you know uh but my dad converted and
they gave him a job and they were gonna
give him a wife
so they they take care of you like that
they'll give you a woman
and now you're in it for life
wow so question is is your family still
ahmadi
about half of them um my parents still
are uh one sibling one brother who's
been trolling me
on twitter for like a year uh
but but but it's funny everything he
says it backfires like he tried to
criticize my arabic
that got smiled to jannah and muzzybuzz
to go through
uh the halifa surah fatiha they found
like 20 plus mistakes
so it's everything that they say against
me alhamdulillah
it backfires on me bro what
sorry not to call you off what's your
brother's name
okay okay because that there's one
brother um who went on smile to janna
and he debated with him on instagram and
that stuff
i want to make sure it wasn't the same
person no it's not that's um
and i think his other name is is osama
or something like that me and him i
actually had a tick tock battle because
so i make a tick tock finally right like
everyone's you got to make a tick tock
account
and expose these guys i'm like no no
a year later i do it i bump into this
guy
he makes a video about me calling me an
alcoholic
calling me uh just you name it and i i
just laugh like i do like
dude i'm in my 40s bro i don't do drugs
i don't even smoke cigarettes dude like
look i got all my hair bro listen
listen bro i i play a lot of basketball
ask
ammunities about me you know because
when i was in my mid-30s
i was or like early 30s i i was still
with gottiany
and i played basketball in the different
leagues i'm still fast that's what i'm
into i try to drink water all day
you know um now i eat hello so as a
gadiani envy we used to eat a taco bell
i mean we'd eat whatever it was not a
big big deal so as i became a muslim you
can't do that
you know so so now i eat from the halal
and in the bay area there's so many
halal joints it's like
you have no excuse so
but i'm sorry i didn't mean to cut you
off you were talking about your family
and getting trolled
on twitter and stuff yeah yeah so so
some of my cousins
are still in it the majority of them out
of respect for their parents have backed
off
you know they just want to back off
their parents will die in the next 10
years the older generation is about
to die off in the next 10 years and then
they'll say something
you know um i i was like the first one
in my family from the men to go to
college
to graduate college so i i felt as if i
was like hey i got nothing
i'm not financially connected to anyone
so i can't i if i got to be the first i
got to be the first man
and and i'm bengali myself so you know i
had a brother reach out to me on
instagram obviously going to leave names
out of this
but he's a subscriber he's a viewer of
our podcast he's bengali too
and he's like bro i'm ahmadi but after
watching some of your videos i'm kind of
questioning my faith
and there's a disparity between uh real
islam and ahmadi
now i'm thinking like bro i was born in
bangladesh
not like i was born here i i lived there
for four or five years
and looking back i didn't i didn't know
anyone that was acne
but you do a little bit of research and
it's like he's there too and you talked
a little bit
about it on twitter but this guy just
doesn't want to leave because he's like
oh he's concerned about his parents but
you know then i started talking to him
and i'm like bro how are you going to
act like ibrahimov didn't have
you know differing views with his own
father when he was getting revelation
right he was an idol worshiper this
isn't you this is this has been from the
dawn of time
and not just um ibrahimovic
he did everything opposite to his uncles
and his dad and
he flipped arabia and said everyone's
wrong
so subhanallah alhamdulillah if i had to
do
something similar at a smaller level i
said okay bro i
i can't keep quiet anymore this is out
of control
on top of that they're robbing my family
for the month
you know on the financial aspect the
time
you know because they have sundays not
sunday school but like general meetings
on sundays
you know and then they got these other
conventions you got to go to and all the
kids are
like cutting school we're all we're all
hanging out in the parking lot we don't
want to listen to these speeches
and we don't want to do all of this so
it's like you know drop the charade
brother
come to islam it's so much easy the
number one
thing i tell them is just pray five
times a day that's literally the
the main part of it you know and then
ramadan comes around
you know and go to the mosque obviously
right now no it's not so easy
but when i go i go to the mosque all the
time bro all the bros in there
we got a basketball court in the back
it's good man
i don't know how it should be talk a
little bit about that going to that so
how much money did they take from you
your family uh just growing
up do you do do you recall them like
your your parents donating or
you know them just subscribing to this
agenda yeah yeah so so
we're in the hood in downtown pittsburgh
california not pittsburgh pennsylvania
you drop the h it's pittsburgh
california and it was named
after pittsburgh pennsylvania it's a
steel town
uh uh there's a huge steel mill and
uh um so america produced more steel in
world war
ii than the entire world combined right
so so this is the major west coast port
uh it's an inland port
um that that's where i'm from um
and uh uh so my dad's got the small
business
instead of us growing our small business
all the profit
my dad's giving up we work seven days a
week
our our house leaks um it's terrible
people
would come to our house and get scared
because of the neighborhood you know
uh and my elder brother you could be in
the hood and not go outside too like
there was there's people who do that
i'm an outside kid i'm outside on my
bike i'm not afraid of anything
all the boys in the hood know who i am
my other brother i had another brother
too
you know um we're not afraid of anything
so you work seven days a week from how
how old were you age seven since i was
seven
from age seven to eighteen i worked
seven days a week with my dad
never missed the day never got a day off
he never gave me a nickel um
and as i graduated high school i started
asking questions okay am i a business
owner do i get added to is this a
partnership
you know i grew up around business i
grew up around my uncle's owning
property
you know um i think allah put it in my
heart the business side
to say hey i'm getting robbed you know
and i'm a big hip-hop head or i used to
be not anymore i'm too old now
but uh um ice cube had the song uh no
vaseline
right and he was talking about business
and he was talking about how
easy he robbed everyone right so i i
kind of had this
in my head and i saw um my dad making
business deals with people
and people would rob him and get over on
him if they were an amateur he wouldn't
care
my dad gave this guy a gas station that
he had he just sold it to him
for here just take the paperwork you
know um
he's giving away stuff he's given uh
these jobs you know people who aren't
qualified how do you hire someone that's
not qualified
you know to work maintenance you know in
maintenance you got to get dumping
you know you got to be dumb and strong
too you know you can't be
like nerdy and know the books you know
you know what i mean
and that's funny because in the air
force i'd be in the classroom a guy
would get a 99 right i'd get like a 91
or something
and then we go out to the aircraft he
can't even lift the toolbox
you know so so like there's a lot more
to it
so i just i saw all that and i said okay
do i get when do i get paid
or do i get paid do i get a car like
what do i get
they're like no you don't get anything
you're our slave
i was like but i i don't want to be a
slave to the amateur movement my whole
life and then i'm 30 years old and i
didn't go to college
i at least need to go to college like
why are we giving everything away
you know it did that's not and as i grew
up i found out that's not even islam
in islam you you have to take care of
your unmarried children
you gotta take care of your parents you
know
these are like requirements in islam you
know and then if you have money left
over you pay
zakat you know and zagat is only
for people who made money not if you're
poor and
and you're living in an area that has
street prostitution is a norm
you know in my in where i live we would
you know
there was homelessness and street
prostitution and they all know us we all
know them
because we walk outside there was no
phones or nothing like that
so we're all outside as much as possible
you know so
so i'd come home from work and my dad
would let us sit in front of the house
and um hang out with our friends in
front of our house till midnight
so we we'd be out there seeing all all
the craziness
you know um and i knew how people were
getting over on people so i'm like dude
i'm not gonna let these guys
rob me even though i still believed him
you know i i said i i'd come back to it
later so
come to find out janda is what they call
it it's not in the quran
not at all you know the only category it
could fit is
is sabaka under sadhuka
that's crazy dude a lot
it's hard to believe that people stay so
dedicated something like that but when
you
add in the fact that they're given all
these you know worldly privileges then
it starts to make sense wow yeah and
their their um their imams are all
doing well so they get the majority of
the money
because i found it on the on the balance
sheet the uh
um the amity murabies get are
living good and they're uh you can call
them the shareholders
so it's the mirza family and their group
of murabis
and their kids are are super dedicated
to the jamaat and they they get other
people to give money
they used to come to my dad's house and
say how many gas stations do you own
you know and then my my dad would like
like and i'm looking at my dad like none
dude we lost them all you gave away
so they'd be like give us give us twenty
thousand and my dad would cough it up
cash geez
she hurts me to see any any wording
online even that
you know when you google ahmed it's a
sector within islam or it is an islamic
movement it's a postmodern liberalized
islamic movement or whatever you see and
it's like i just hate this
thai with islam
yep and so um they're just like the
baha'is
uh baha'u'llah also claimed to be a like
asa alas long
he had a lot of similar beliefs and
mirza guam and
copied but the baha'is separated from
islam
and that's what what what is the
difference whereas
um um these uh gadiani and these are
looking to substitute
islam they're looking to get muslims to
convert
so that's why muslims in you know in
pakistan in 1974
uh they were declared non-muslim
by like the constitution
you know um yeah so so
so then in 1984 so
so then they got the persecution angle
they're like oh we're a persecuted
community community
a lot of people in america i knew people
who converted just because ahmadiyya
was allegedly a persecuted community and
they never read no arguments they just
want to be
part of a persecuted community and
that's weird but whatever
you know and then uh the kadiani amnesia
will make a parallel to muhammad
sallallahu and the early mecca muslims
and say we're persecuted just like them
yeah so how's your relationship with
your parents now
uh they won't answer my phone calls uh
we had a dude we had squashed it a year
ago
about a year ago one of my cousins died
and my parents squashed it with me some
of my nephews were like
you know in in islam you can't keep a
grudge with your brother for more than
three days it's in the hadith
you can't do it you know why why are you
guys boycotting him
so um so my dad called the truce
but it didn't it didn't last more than
two weeks you know he all of a sudden
he doesn't want me speaking about
ahmadiyya
you know and i'm like so you want to
silence me i'm like
this is like a strategy from the
headquarters of amethyst silence him
well okay i'll be friends with you again
if you silence yourself
and i'm like but i i mean why
why is that the you know i i don't go to
my dad and say hey let's talk about
religion i want to go fishing with them
and just say i love you know i mean
let's hang out
talk basketball uh um talk football
talk baseball something other than
religion you know same thing with my
brother
i don't talk religion all the time with
people you know it's not like the main
topic that comes up
you know it's other things you know i
play a little chess too i'm not that
good at it but
you know um there's so many other things
that we can do matt
you know but they got great
for me but whatever i'm i'm also like 40
something so it's like not like i'm
you know when you're in your 20s you're
you like all my parents and when you're
older it's like
i'm a parent so but still like this
that's your parents you know it's like
that is tough nonetheless
yeah yeah may allah
y'all got any questions before i go to
the next one no
go ahead so brother bashir you made it
you made it
unequivocally established that it is so
difficult to get in but it's even more
difficult to get out
what do they do with people that want to
leave what do they do with people that
want to
you know wake up kind of just accept
reality and realize i've kind of been
lied to all my life you know we'll talk
about you know what you know your advice
to ahmed khan
is what they can do but the people that
do want to leave
how did they leave how did you leave
what happened when you left did anyone
help you were there was the opposition
yeah yeah yeah so so my story is a
little bit different because i lost my
job
i lost my wife i lost uh
basically i didn't lose my kids though
because i've always had 50 50 custody
i lost my family uh not all of them
though just you know
uh like the backwards ones i guess the
immigrants i guess like the american
born are cool
i still talk to them all the time we
even hang out
play sports together um
i would suggest if at first it's
financial independence
you have to become financially
independent before you make your jump
uh slowly back away and then get your
money right
you know when once you get your money
right it'll be easier you can get an
apartment you can move out
but the boycott's gonna happen it's
there's no way it's not gonna happen
um they cry about persecution they
persecute ex-army
all the time they um my dad told me i i
would die
miserably and i had to be like damn pop
i was like that i don't believe that
about you
i hope nothing happens to you or mom or
my older brother
i pray for you guys to come to islam
it's not up to me it's up to allah
and uh you know my financial
independence really really helped me and
i was older
so what do you tell a teenager you know
what i mean the teenagers
it depends on where you're at in life
you know but um
just be very cautious you know i didn't
run and
and and go and become a muslim like the
next day and
uh except i took time you know um
so so everyone's different reach out to
me there's many whatsapp groups i'm
actually working with
with like 20 to 40 uh x families that
are muslim right now
unfortunately most examinees become
atheists
in the west uh there's about a thousand
of them
in this reddit forum and i've been
banned like seven eight times
because i'm muslim and they don't like
muslims over there
right so uh just come back to the quran
you know islam is easy islam in the
quran is easy
so um find me on the internet find my
blog
or if that doesn't work um most aunties
in the west
are aren't living with family friends
so like it's easier to disconnect you
know i didn't grow up in that circle
like
where i'm from there wasn't that many
md's anyway in in the bay area let me
just clarify
there's probably a thousand total and
that number is dying fast
out of those thousand about half of them
are new generation kids
who stop showing up stop giving money so
they're already gone
so um it's just a matter of time so
i guess that's the best advice i can
give brothers
and what's what's uh your blog called
where can people find it
you'll find the instagram page you'll
find the tick tock you'll find
uh twitter on twitter i use my real name
uh at
beshear capital a underscore shaw
um uh yeah on facebook too
uh i just downloaded telegram because
some uh
some new uh examinees wanted to talk to
me on telegram
i'm on whatsapp too there's so many
channels it's out of control
you sent me some of your your your
things on whatsapp so i'm gonna link all
of them
you can always you know get in touch
with me uh as soon as we've done this
and
i will remember to link everything and
guys if you don't follow anyone if you
don't support anyone support this
brother because
he doesn't get money out of this he
doesn't he doesn't get compensation out
of this
if anything he's just getting more
enemies out of this for speaking the
truth
so if you want to follow someone you
want to support someone you want to
share any video
it has to be this video
please do you know and we're we're
trying to shut down ahmadiyya
and bring bring brothers to uh um to
islam
and i you know my youtube channel is not
monetized this is my hobby my number one
hobby
basically it was pick up basketball but
now you know
and hopefully pick up basketball come
back you know but i've done
enough work to last me a few years so
no worries perfect and for anyone before
we wrap it up that wants to check out
your blog
what will they find it they will find
the truth about islam
so for example uh the twists and the
turns
some muslims said um isa al-islam
might have died before he was rafa and
and allah is going to give him a new
body well this is
it's it's we don't know you know these
are things that are
we don't know how allah got
issa last long to bring a dead person
back to life we don't know
we don't know how allah made the stick
of moses turn into a snake
we don't know what we do know is isa
al-islam bin muryam
is going to physically return to the end
days that's a
certainty there's yakin on this right
so we stick and when it comes to islam
stick to the clear things
don't go to the vagueness and try to
find a way out
hundred percent um in in chapter three
verse seven
allah says uh this is this is you know
the the quran which we revealed
in it are verses which are clear and
they're the foundation of the book and
other verses are ambiguous
and allah actually talks about the
people who rely on the ambiguous verses
in false interpretation
to spread misguidance and mischief in
the land allah already talks about it
allah is basically telling us don't take
the ambiguous verses
as foundational ones because you're just
going to end up
spreading this guidance with your your
misinterpretation subhanallah
i feel like summarized
subhanallah yup you hit the nail on the
head brother
absolutely all right brother inshallah
we get you back on um
sometime this should be more than enough
for people to
not only get more information on
ahmadiyya but some information
if they didn't even have any if they
came here and they saw this title and
they're like
what is what is ahmed what does that
mean but hopefully now they have
something to take home something to
share with their family something to
share with their friends
maybe even some something to contemplate
on if they're in that position that you
were once upon a time brother
but it takes courage so i commend you um
barakallah feek
and uh to anyone watching uh remember
subscribe
tune in follow this brother
i got some last words though let me go
for it one last argument
don't believe that islam was
miraculously born
therefore talifa
said uh miriam was a hermaphrodite
and she impregnated herself so
and then that is just i mean how wild
can we get
then the lahorian these they said that
islam had a biological father
so it's just it's just uh the more you
read the more
ridiculous things you will find and the
shout outs
in pakistan we have many channels of
sham zadine
um irfan but ak sheikh from canada
omar han from california is my boy um
who else and i'm i'm blanking right now
um
uh hakuma nabua channel we got urdu
stuff
we got german stuff we're we're hitting
these guys hard with love
with compassion uh farhan yusuf zai
he's my boy uh uh and we
we are here and we're here to give this
information with love to amity's we
don't hate any amnes
we love you guys we just want to bring
you guys home
and that's it happy may allah bless you
and all the brothers on this project and
reward you for all the good we do and
grant you the highest levels of um
if you made it this far in the podcast
comment true islam
in the comments may allah bless you all
foreign
as rami said may allah bless you all for
watching
with that being so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
uh